[Music]
American Idol Alum Kelly pickler's
husband Kyle Jacobs has died he was 49
years old what's not to love oh my gosh
he um definitely has all of the
qualities that I lack Nashville law
enforcement says it's assumed Jacobs
died by Suicide at the couple's home we
are told when Pickler couldn't find her
husband on Friday morning she and her
assistant went to look for him and when
they were unable to open an upstairs
door the assistant called 9-1-1 Pickler
and Jacobs a country music songwriter
married in 2011. I love so much about my
beautiful wife I mean not only is she
beautiful and just incredible but she's
a conqueror and she is just one of the
smartest people I've ever met ever and
I'm just going so
well stop now
no I'm just so thankful to have her in
my life I really truly am love and
laughter I mean that's definitely two
main ingredients in life that's our life
that's what we strive for in our life is
just is to laugh as much as possible
[Music]